[music playing]
We're headed to a warehouse.
This one has a lot of
European shipments,
South American shipments, a
lot of source countries for us
for narcotics.
So we're gonna see what
we can find over here.
[music playing]
Albert, take a look at this.
Ecuador.
What is that?
I don't know.
Let's find out.
It's, like, blankets.
Ecuador is a big
transit point now for dope
coming out from South America.
Heroin, cocaine, we used to
get stuff in the embroidery
of this, inside the lining.
A lot of times, what they
try to do is nickel and dime.
So they'll put little
baggies of coke
inside of little handicrafts.
You always got to check.
You gotta cut it open.
This one is what it is.
OFFICER RAMIREZ: All
right, I've seen enough.
Yeah.
[music playing]
Coming from Mexico.
Yeah.
It's all food and breads.
OFFICER TWAROWSKI: In
here, you got peanuts.
Tamales.
Looks like a lot of
shipments coming from Mexico.
Mexico, a big source country.
Cocaine, heroin,
fentanyl, every--
Meth.
--you know, meth, everything.
So what they like to do
is they like to conceal it
inside the food a lot of times.
They think it's going
to fool the x-rays.
Or they think it's going
to fool us, you know.
We're not going to
take a look at it.
But we take a look
at everything.
You know, we have to.
Those are Chilean apples.
Those are bigger.
So it's a different fruit.
OFFICER RAMIREZ: Nothing.
Not as sticky.
ASSISTANT PORT
DIRECTOR GALANTINO:
It's funny that those
were a different color.
[music playing]
There's another one.
Now, we're separating
the actual contraband
itself from the fruit.
I wish they'd chosen
something that was less syrupy.
They think we're not going
to get our hands dirty.
So what do you got there?
OFFICER TWAROWSKI: Five, seven.
ASSISTANT PORT DIRECTOR
GALANTINO: This one has--
yep, seven.
What we do now, we're
going to use our Gemini
machine to just confirm.
[music playing]
There you go.
It's cocaine hydrochloride.
OFFICER RAMIREZ: Get
a weight on this.
OFFICER TWAROWSKI: All right.
[music playing]
0.391 kilograms.
ASSISTANT PORT DIRECTOR
GALANTINO: I mean, they were
not greedy, not greedy at all.
OFFICER RAMIREZ: Not at all.
And we have to dig through all
this food to get a small load.
And this, we've been
seeing more and more,
the smaller amounts.
I think they're testing
out different concealments
and seeing what they
can get through.
They don't want to
lose a big shipment.
Now, we're going
to notify HSI.
And they're ultimately
going to take possession
of the narcotics themselves.
And they may do a
controlled delivery to find
out who this was going to.
OFFICER TWAROWSKI: Right.
And then perhaps
develop a case from this.
At the end of the day, it's
about disbanding these drug
trafficking organizations.
This shipment here, this is
just one of those 300 or 400
that come in
multiple times a day.
See what else they got.